well it's been another weekend I hope
everybody's weekend was good here in the
United States we had 11 mass shootings
this weekend and more than 300 shootings
altogether those are the right numbers
do not adjust your television do not
punch your phone screen do not throw it
in the toilet and flush it those are the
real numbers 11 mass shootings Friday to
Sunday and more than 300 shootings total
in terms of the mass shootings we had
four on Friday
three on Saturday
and four on Sunday now understand that
in the U.S we have categories of
shootings that don't exist in the entire
world you look at Serbia for example and
what recently happened there with
shootings and you see that there are
categories here that would sound crazy
Elsewhere for example in the United
States we have regular shootings not
mass shootings where one or two people
are killed or injured and many that's a
regular shooting you then have mass
shootings where you have three people
injured or killed in total or more and
then you have
nationally
uh uh covered mass shootings which are
mass shootings that the country takes an
interest in interest in and indeed uh
but by the way if you're interested
about these numbers go to
gunviolencearchive.org you can see the
mass shootings you can see all shootings
over the last 72 hours for example you
know this morning there have already
been shootings in Los Angeles to in
Texas this uh or I'm sorry one in Texas
was this morning one was yesterday okay
so you you kind of get the picture
some of these make National headlines
for example the one in Allen Texas did
this was at the Allen Premium Outlets
where eight victims were killed seven
were injured and the shooter was quote
neutralized for a report by Fox 4 that
one received extensive coverage many
politicians weighing in about it we'll
dig into that one in more detail a
little bit later but then there are
other mass shootings that get less
attention for example there was the one
in St Louis Missouri where two teens
were killed and two others were injured
this was yesterday morning Sunday
morning this one got local coverage but
didn't really get National coverage
that's because in the United States Mass
shoot not just shootings are so common
mass shootings are so common that it's
got to be really depraved and deranged
like particularly sick to even make
National headlines and again that's just
mass shootings then we have just kind of
like your run-of-the-mill shootings for
example these these aren't even a blip
on the radar for most of the country uh
this one was in Pendleton Indiana
where a man was found shot to death and
police are seeking The public's help
this this is sort of like you're more
pedestrian mass shooting for lack of a
better term so this is the day-to-day
reality in the United States and we
continue to have and we're going to
delve into this we continue to have a
political contingent that wants to do
nothing other than offer prayers
sometimes thoughts sometimes they will
think about it but often it's just
they'll pray sometimes thoughts and
prayers sometimes just prayers and uh
when I suggested of course on Twitter
that the prayer doesn't really seem to
help even even Christian schools have
been shot up and certainly there's
prayer happening there I'm the bad guy
rather than all the people who want to
do absolutely nothing we then have
elected officials who choose instead to
focus on Mental Health yet they don't
want to fund Mental Health Services or
they want to focus on violent video
games even when there's no evidence that
the shooter played video games you've
all gotten to know this endless routine
that we have in the United States
another aspect to the cycle of course
the sick Insidious cycle
is right when there's a major again I'm
using the crazy terminology when we have
a major mass shooting of natural
interest National interest we should
have an abbreviation for that uh there
are many people who say now that this is
again in the spotlight as it is every
few days we should really do something
about gun safety laws and these are very
popular proposals we saw even a Fox News
poll last week said that most Americans
favor requiring a background check in
every case of a gun transaction even
between private individuals but these
things are very popular
oh we can't politicize this in the
immediate aftermath tensions are running
High the families haven't buried their
debt you hear all this stuff but we do
send our thoughts and prayers either you
thoughts and prayers you can do at any
time and then a little while goes by and
then hopefully the people seeking to
make change hopefully I mean from the
perspective of the gun people the people
seeking to make change forget or they
move on or whatever the case may be and
then nothing happens and then we have
our next major mass shooting of national
interest and then same cycle over and
over and over again I have to tell you
though we did hear from a few people
after the shooting in Allen Texas who
were stepping out of their you might
call it their prescribed uh characters
and actually said things that make a lot
of sense I want to look at a couple
examples of this with you right now